you know I think of all the the
fictional characters of the last few
weeks I think my favorite are the
peaceful protesters because while Batman
might be a cooler figure the peaceful
protesters are just so much more
fantastical they've made a new
appearance this this and the BBC an
actual BBC headline George Floyd London
anti racism protests leave 27 officers
hurt okay that's sort of a more
believable title here's how they tweeted
out the headline 27 police officers
injured during largely peaceful anti
racism protests in London that is not
possible that is that tweet is a
nonsense because 27 cops can't be
injured in largely peaceful protests you
can't have those things at the same time
from the article protests on Saturday
sparked by the death of George Floyd is
that true we'll get to that in a second
we're largely peaceful but were marred
later by disturbances outside of Downing
Street you know they were largely
peaceful to protest themselves but they
were marred that's unfortunate because
they were so peaceful but they were
marred later by disturbances not
violence not the people committing the
violence one demonstrator who is not a
Downing Street saw officers acting very
aggressively elsewhere
it was the officers acting aggressively
you see and they shouldn't do that
that's not not what officers are for
they're not there to use force they're
there to enforce the law wait a second
force and force let's not let's ignore
it let's ignore that the entire purpose
of the police is to use force for just
one second the majority of Saturday's
protests were peaceful but in the
evening there were disturbances outside
Downing Street BBC home affairs
correspondent Tom Simmons said the
protests were largely over when missiles
and fireworks were thrown at a police
line they were thrown and not by the
protesters just they just were thrown
two officers were seriously injured
including a mounted branch officer who
was knocked from her horse when it hit a
set of traffic lights while appearing to
bolt
she suffered a broken collarbone a
broken rib a punctured lung
according to the Metropolitan Police
Federation
that's not nothing okay those are real
injuries those are serious injuries
those were caused by the allegedly
nonviolent protests now you can actually
see their number of videos that came out
the protests got so violent that the
police eventually ran away from the
so-called peaceful protesters you can
see there's some sort of chaos there
they're what people are throwing things
at the cops cops in America not quite as
well armed as her cops in Britain rather
not quite as well armed as those in
America eventually the police are
running away as these goons these thugs
these criminals are throwing objects at
them a lot of problems with policing in
the UK obviously they are not armed
to do the job that they're supposed to
do but the question here is why are
there protests going on in the United
Kingdom over the death of George Floyd
is it because people in the UK Brits
just really have a connection to this
man in Minneapolis and half the half a
world away in the United States I don't
think so I think there's a deeper
ideological political rebellion going on
here
[Music]
you
[Music]